I was always a dog person anyways yes
I'm recording this in pajamas I'm not
getting properly dressed to shoot this
thing I don't even know why I'm talking
about saying I don't know how I'll watch
this thing cats
um and I am legitimately not sober right
now because that was the plan all along
I capped off my workweek by getting by
getting through Amazon Prime renting
cats with my partner Liz and we worked
at a whole bunch of our burlesque
friends and he we go watched cats this
is either going to be an uncut mess or
it's gonna have about five thousand
Anna's because I'm not editing this
drawing I'm gonna head it it's over but
yeah now there's gonna be if you looking
for a full dissection there's gonna be
no proper I'm not formulating I don't
have a plan out of a point but then
again neither did this movie hey we're
off to a good start so a little bit of
background cats is not a show that I've
ever seen on Broadway and it's not a
show I've ever wanted to see what little
I could find out about it like what I've
seen a lot of shows on Broadway I've
seen a ton actually I've seen Chicago
I've seen lame is I've seen rent I have
seen Beauty and the Beast I've seen
Avenue Q I've seen wicked I've seen The
Lion King
I see I've um and then I've seen some
when I was in London got over a decade
ago God like 15 years ago crap anyways
that I saw things like blood brothers
and
was I've seen a lot of really good
professional theater and a lot of
different varieties I've seen drama The
Musical I've seen big spectral have seen
small intimate I never had the desire to
see cats ever at any point because I
didn't get it and I knew I didn't get it
I could tell just looking at them images
hearing the songs I'm like I don't get
this that's not to say that the stage
version of cats is bad there has to be
something to it it ran for freaking ever
but so far as I can understand having
talked to some people who actually like
the stage version what works about it
are things that don't translate as well
to film either not either film is not
built to do it as well as theater is or
they just don't translate it all so like
cats the musical has no fourth wall
the cats are constantly adjusting the
audience directly which doesn't really
work in film film is I mean that you can
break the fourth wall but the assumption
is that there's always one there you in
theater you can establish early on nope
no fourth wall and just go you can do
that that doesn't really work in film
there's a lot of actually very direct
audience interactions obviously you
can't do that in film it's a heavy dance
number which I'm not saying you can't
have dance numbers in film but it's not
the same because with all the cuts and
everything you can tell that they were
able to stitch together multiple takes
it's not the same as watching the human
body go through these core these moves
in this choreography for an extended
period without cuts it's not the same
dance does not translate as well into
film and it doesn't play as well as it
does live-action and plus the whole show
really has no plot it's a review style
show or just cat sing about themselves
or about another cat there isn't really
a plot to be said and movies without
plots that doesn't really work again
because the suspension of disbelief is
already much higher I'm swaying a lot
inherently with theatre you can get away
with breaking a few more rules because
you're already asking more of your
so the very idea of making a film
version of cats was a bad idea to begin
with because what makes it work at least
so far as I understand it is all stuff
that either doesn't translate or does
not work as effectively in film and then
what you're left with is a meandering
nonsensical plotless story in film and
that's basically what the movie is but
yet it's somehow worse than that because
they try to give it a plot but not like
enough that they bother to restructure
the thing they just try and force a plot
in their very crowbarred in like one of
the people was in the the group chat
that we had going on I was a fan of the
stage show so she was always quick to
point out oh no that's not that's not
from the show that'd that they changed
this but honestly what makes this thing
the strangest freaking thing that I have
seen in a while
it is not it has nothing to do with
adaptation choices although even if this
thing had been executed at a much better
level than what it is it still would
have been a bad movie because they were
staying true to something that was built
for a medium that is totally different
it was just yeah so I don't think this
movie was ever gonna be good but the
weight the way that it's done with this
freaky uncanny valley for some time the
face doesn't totally line up with the
head or sometimes the head looks like
it's a little too small and the scale is
inconsistent from scene to scene and the
bizarre transitions it's just why why
did anyone think this was a good idea
why would you do the cats like that like
just basic things just
decide if your cats walk on two legs or
four don't keep going back and forth
especially when you are dealing with
human beings that you are leaving with
human being proportions and when they
get out on all fours it's really weird
and awkward you can tell the actors
don't really know what to do with it so
it's already awkward sit watching some
stand and some crawl but then having to
see some of them a transition from one
to the other that's always a friggin
visual trainwreck even aside from the
effects because the effects the effects
in many cases look flat-out unfinished
and this is there's no official word on
this because the people who worked on it
won't talk because talking crap about a
production is a good way to ensure that
you don't work again on future ones so
nobody's really talking but the word on
the rumor mill that it has no official
backing behind it but makes a heck of a
lot of sense is that Universal basically
stopped spending money on the special
effects once the reaction to the trailer
came in and it was nothing but mockery I
don't mean like they they weren't
willing to pay for anymore effects work
but they they pulled money from this
thing is the word and that means that
there are literally effects that are not
finished they needed it another Polish
and the cats are probably the best but
like all the things that aren't the cats
are like really freaky like these they
got mice with children's faces and it is
one of the freakiest freaking things
I've ever seen it's not from the fact
that that concept in and of itself is
horrifying it looks terrible and like
again part of this is execution and part
of this is what were you thinking why
does rebel Wilson unzip her skin and
like have an outfit on underneath that
twice she does he twice and Macavity oh
god okay so Macavity that's injures
Elba's character I can remember his name
because oh my god so the way they dealt
with the fact that they had a whole
bunch of very high profile stars who
weren't gonna stick around for the
entire shoot of this thing
so again backing up the way the stage
play works like I've seen dissections of
this thing before I actually watched it
so I thought I knew I what I was getting
into I didn't you can't be prepared for
this but like having so I know enough
about the stage play so in the in the
stage version basically nearly the
entire cast is on the stage for almost
the entire show whose front and center
and getting the focus on them shifts but
they're all there for the whole time
there was no way that they were gonna
get that in this case even though
they've got a whole chorus of cats
because they got a whole bunch of top
line celebrities they got it you're
celibate rebel Wilson Judi Dench James
Corden Taylor Swift Jennifer Hudson all
these people who were not gonna stick
around for the entire length of the
shoot so all the cats that those
characters played get removed from the
proceedings in which doesn't happen on
this show and the way they do that is to
have macavity who isn't really a filler
at least I don't think but they tried to
make him into like a proper villian in
their attempt to have this have a why
it's not supposed to have one anyways
he's vanishing them and like trapping
them on on a boat in the Thames and the
reason I can remember yeah I just
remember why I started this tangent the
reason I can remember the cavity's name
is because when he vanishes Ian McKellen
he goes
I'm gonna start just doing that like
just when I leave the room Oh does that
mention ian mckellen he's one of the few
who comes off fairly decently and this
partly because like the effect looks
much better on him I don't know if it's
just his face lent itself to it a bit
more maybe honestly maybe it's the
wrinkles in the aged because honestly
it's the youngest actors with the fewest
lines on their faces who look the most
uncanny so maybe that's part of it um
but he looked pretty good he performed
his bit well Jennifer Hudson's the other
one who's too good for this injury cell
bomb I'm not gonna say he elevated what
he was given but I do think he might
have been the only one who knew what
kind of movie he was in cuz everyone
else is taking this Jeff Lee seriously
to the point that I'm just like dude his
cats lighten up I'm gonna blame the
director on that Tom that's your fault
but yeah if Macavity the colour they
decided to make his fur is basically the
same colour that interest Elba is and
they don't break it up like with stripes
or spots or anything so most of the
movie he's got a hat and a coat that's
fine but then when he shows up for his
big number and then from then on he just
looks naked like way more than anyone
else in the movie he looks he looks
naked and it's really just and like a
lot of these cats are really horny the
way they act they're all like
it's it's very like what the would ah
like some of them like they they'll do
these these like these leg bends or
these back arches and like stop it's one
of those look I'm not truck I'm not
trying to judge anybody but I know this
is theoretically supposed to be a family
show I know it is on Broadway and
theoretically this was supposed to be to
and I'm not turned on by that but I know
there are people who are and I feel like
you're playing into that in a way that
makes me uncomfortable no judgement on
whatever you like but don't claim this
is a family movie and have horny rides
and cat people things that don't even
look like cast they look like we're cast
they look like human I'm stealing this
observation from somebody else in the
chat so kitten if you see this that
credit to you for that but they look
like they look like humans who are 5/6
of the way through a we're cat
transformation like it hasn't worked its
way up to the face yet and they just
froze that's what they look like I'm not
necessarily gonna recommend this
experience to anybody I'm kind of glad I
did it as a communal experience because
pain shared is pain halved or decimated
I don't know how many of us were on the
call but if you gotta watch this watch
it watch it with a buddy did it do the
buddy system so that you know you're
safe because what were they thinking
what were they thinking what were they
think I'm not we're saying that three
times because like that's how big the
question is I mean what were they
thinking adapting this in the first
place what were they thinking hiring a
director whose vision was to try and
make this weird semi-realistic gritty
thing out of something that has no
business being shot and portrayed and
and lit and done that way and
just the fur well what were they
thinking what were they thinking what
were they thinking I don't know but
that's cat
I'm gonna go collapse and stuff you know
things like subscribe it's on that side
I think Bell patreon stuff you don't
have to do it though cuz end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council needs to sober up and stop
saying the word Jellicle my Goffe say
like 50 times
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]